good afternoon everybody my name is mark
mason i work for nature's reward
farms out of
salinas california
i'm a farm manager for the company
i'm also a certified crop advisor and a
pest control advisor for the company
my role within the company is i'm in
charge of all the pesticides and the
fertility which includes the water
inputs and the nitrogen
fertilizer inputs or all the fertilizer
inputs for the ranch
a little bit about the company
we're a fourth generation family farm
we farm
on about 6 000 land acres
in salinas valley
and it's two crops
so that's about 12 000 we do like 2.1
crops so it's a little over twelve
thousand crop acres
and it's year-round production
in the two different regions which would
be salinas valley
california and then also yuma arizona
region
we are vertically integrated so we've
got our
farming department as well as our
harvest
our sales and marketing
we also have within the farm we have a
fertility department for the
crops and then also we've got our pest
control department
the crops that we grow
we grow lettuce
broccoli
cauliflower
celery
strawberries um and then we have minor
crops that we grow like in dives grill
kale
some sprouts some swiss chard
so just a real quick
um
background of salinas valley so the
lettuce production in salinas valley
is a planting from mid-december to
mid-august with the harvest of mid-march
to the end of october
the depending on when you plant it's
anywhere from a 65 day
head lettuce crop to 120 days
and then when production is not during
this time frame it's in the arizona area
according to the monterey county crop
report from 2018 which is the most
recent
this is a
1.2 billion dollar production value for
lettuce and this includes
um head lettuce leaf lettuce romaine
mixed lettuce not baby green lettuce
um just the commodity type lettuces and
then the number two crop would be
broccoli for 2018. it's probably a
similar trend um
that lettuce is still number one
um so as we look at our sustainability
plan
um you know there's a couple things that
drive what we're doing as far as the
sustainability there's the county
regional and state
and federal regulations
that they require
upon us as growers
and
there are the retail outlets so the
buyers ask for
certain things
to do on the ranch possibly
or they may ask for certain things for
us
not to do um
activities
they may ask us not to do maybe
certain pesticides they don't want us to
use
um
and then you know the third thing here
is
part of our sustainability is you know
we we're doing a lot of stuff on our own
so we try to take care of the ground and
take care of the water
um
and so we're being proactive
on
on the ground water trying to take care
of the groundwater every all of the
irrigation that we have in salinas
valley is well water so it's all pumped
um
so
you know we're trying to take care of
the natural resources as well as
think ahead you know what's what's going
to be required of the regulators
or the retail outlets in five years from
now 10 years from now 20 years from now
and trying to to adopt maybe some of
those practices
ahead of schedule so non-production you
know just real quick um these are just
some of the things that we've attacked
that um
are part of a sustainability program
solar panels uh paperless farming so you
know we're using tablets instead of
uh you know electronic tablets instead
of clipboards with schedules and
um you know there's no time sheets
there's it's all uh pet tiger
as a program for time sheets
uh electronic program
variable drive irrigation wells to try
to
reduce
pg e
power um we've fenced the salinas river
to prevent trash from blowing into the
river the river drains into the pacific
ocean
so we get a lot of trash coming from
highway 101
so we've have fenced our have fenced
where our ranch borders the rivers huge
recycling program of drip tape
plastic mulch which we use for our
strawberries a huge recycling program of
all of our pesticide
containers and harvest or pesticide
cardboard boxes
and harvest cardboard
and then as well as our pesticide
plastic containers
so in our sustainability plan
you know there's a couple pesticides
that
that are targets that we're trying to
reduce we're we're definitely trying to
reduce all
pesticides but there's some
and you know neonics and pyrethroids are
kind of the poster child of of products
that need to be reduced
so one way that we're doing this is
we're using smart spray technology so
when the lettuce is small the sprayer
comes through it
only sprays
what it sees
so
there's a huge savings in products
applied
at this point
grassed waterways so
we try to grasp the
waterways
that carry storm water or possible tail
water
and a lot of times that tail water may
have
some of these pesticides in it and so
the grass waterways
are there to help filter
use kind of as filter strips to filter
out some of this some of these
pesticides to prevent them from going
into
a discharge point which will eventually
end up
possibly to the salinas river and into
the ocean
um and then our pollination our
pollinator strategy
so
uh you know we've encouraged vegetation
where we can
in non
farm areas
non-crop areas i guess i should say
and then also you know production
or or spraying at night so when we go
out and spray
we try to do most if not all of our
spraying is done in the evenings this is
also to help to help with
avoiding
non-target
drift from uh wind salinas can get windy
so
again we spray at night for that reason
also
nitrogen use efficiency um as the crops
get
uh
ready for fertilizer we will go out and
pull a soil sample
and verify that
they need fertilizer so we run it
through a computer program called crop
manage which was developed by michael
khan university of california
we will put the night the soil sample
results from a quick test into the crop
manage system makes a recommendation
and
we take that recommendation as a tool
we
can um
use it use the number that it's given us
or we can
change it
as we see fit as managers um
that's been a huge part of our lettuce
production in the last
five years i would say
high carbon compost the idea here is
that we put on high carbon compost in
the fall
and as the rains come
so it'll be high carbon compost in the
fall after
you know say a lettuce crop has been
harvested and the idea here is is that
when the rains come
the carbon has binded with the nitrogen
and when it rains it's not leached and
then in the spring
when we're ready to plant this uh
nitrogen becomes available um
number three here will be a smart side
dress
of fertilizer so it's same technology as
the smart spray
and
you know this is still in development
but the idea here is that we
go instead of making a line of
fertilizer we
put the machine in there and whenever it
sees we set the parameters of you know
when you see a
uh a lettuce plant we want to fertilize
you know two inches on each side of that
plant
and so then you're going through in your
smart side dressing
and then
to water use efficiency
we are again back to crop manage using
crop manage for irrigation
recommendations we're using it as a
we're using it as a tool
to help
manage our irrigation scheduling
and it uses et
to help make these recommendations and
then we're also using the open et
which
will
help us determine
how much water
is needed to just replace what the plant
is using so the you know the et is just
the minimum that it takes to produce the
crop you know we we definitely use water
more than the e.t in certain situations
whether it's a leaching
or soil type
but we're using this et as the starting
point
and then buried drip tape for lettuce
germination that way we avoid
wind
patterns from the sprinklers
and um
when we've got
wind patterns at 10 we tend to use a lot
more water than necessary
so
you know the wind blows constantly a lot
of times in the area so it's hard to
avoid these wind patterns and
and then crop uniformity you know this
is uh i see uniformity
and high yields as
a way to
to make us more sustainable i mean it
makes sense
to me that as your yield and your
uniformity increases and some of these
inputs
maybe stay the same
you've got you know less
less
less natural resources i guess you could
say per unit harvested
so that's going to be on this next slide
here so
um as we get
more uniform and higher yields we have
i'm going to call it a fixed input
per unit harvested so if we can get more
boxes off the same acre
with um you know every time we run a
tractor through right it's the same
amount of fuel per acre and
you know water may change a little bit
fertilizer may change a little bit as
you get these higher yields or
um
you know pesticides aren't going to
change right it's just the same amount
per acre and unless you're talking the
smart spray
so i think all of these
fixed inputs
um
kind of are reduced per unit as we get
our crops more uniform
and higher yielding
um so you know to finish off um
as
thinking for the future on uniformity um
you know mechanical harvest or and it's
gonna be destructive harvest in my
opinion
uniformity is going to be the key
and
that's going to be what we need as well
as the plant structure is going to need
to be built
to accommodate these harvesters that are
going to come in high-rise broccoli is a
good example there's some iceberg
lettuce that may sit up 2-3 inches off
the ground
um you know those are going to be
i think as we get into mechanical
harvest is are what we need and the and
then it needs to be uniform as it's
going to be destructive uh as you get
more uniform there's some harvest models
developed
by some drone companies that work pretty
well
but um you know uniformity is going to
be
is going to be key in making these work
and then as you get more uniform then
you know you've got less food loss um so
that's important also
so
um
and again you know the last point here
is going to be that as
yields increase and and the uniformity
is there it fits into our
sustainability goal
so with that um i'll wrap it up i think
i'm pretty close to on time and uh thank
you i'll be
available for questions thanks